okay
for people joining this live stream this
is one of our continuing series of
meetings about language completeness and
consistency
fall from language we appear to have
a modest collection of easy topics today
but
it often starts looking that way and
doesn't end that way
okay so
this one is hopefully an easy we
discussed this one last time
and you approved it under the name
arguments options list
and before we merged it jose had this
suggestion that maybe we should just
call it argument
options because normally as it says
there when we
call things uh
you know list argument options
list it's still called arguments options
list
because that was the name from the last
meeting
it's not the uh it should be
okay tries to separate arguments into
positional
oh maybe we haven't updated the verbiage
like we should do right but that's the
thing that returns it it returns a pair
of positional arguments and options
i see
so but it does so by doing what by
so it has a i mean this thing has to not
evaluate
correct
or does it not evaluate itself what do
you mean does it not evaluate itself
um this thing that you give it if i
if i put you know fine shortest tour or
something
and it's got something in there that's
going to evaluate it before this
function even sees it
no because this function is hold first
otherwise it would be completely useless
okay fine
just like any sort of testing function
right but the point is that the
implementation
of that function um
is the thing that's probably calling
arguments options list
and so its arguments will presumably
have evaluated already unless
um the function that function itself
is has some kind of hold attribute
right but that's what you were thinking
but but this is going to be called okay
i agree with you it should be called
arguments options
okay um but this thing is going to be
called
not during the evaluation of f but
outside of f
it's going to but it's going to be
called by
the you know basically by the down
values of f
how with condition
because that's how the author of f
implemented
f yes it's not it's there's no magic
that causes this function to evaluate
on arbitrary functions no i understand
but what does the code look like i mean
so it says
f of x triple blank
then what uh sla
you know get slash semi uh
you know arguments options
uh well i get i guess if uh
well this is a you know that's not right
i mean what you want to do
yeah on the right-hand side yeah you'll
want to call it on the right-hand side
right
gets you know and then
put it like that what i would do is to
put a colon equal dollar failed
and then the condition and this is the
last value
well well no that's for that's for test
arguments
which gives you the boolean of whether
it passed the test or not i mean this is
for a slightly
different where you will right i mean
there's an example
in the application section of how you
might use it
um right i confused it with the other
one
oh gosh you know this is not the most
beautiful workflow
it's it's how things have been
implemented
for i know yeah we should figure out how
to do it better
well such functions may
right right i think it's more useful
cousin
is is is the test arguments version
which just returns true or false and
then you put your glass
down right then the last down value is
like jose suggested
um and and that way it issues sort of
messages for all the
you know wrong number of arguments and
invalid options
etcetera how this relates to
christopher's confirm
enclosed framework well
i mean it's in the same well christopher
should be here with us
um if he's not then we'll probably want
to skip the next item
um but can we find him
he doesn't seem to be on this list so
can somebody try to find him
yeah um
but um i mean they're sort of playing
around
i mean this is just this is this is
automating the process of testing
arguments uh you know argument counts
and you know when you have ambiguities
between what are arguments and what are
options
what would you really like it to do i
mean so a typical pattern here that we
would do
is to say you know f of x triple blank
you know opts colon options pattern
of blah right colon equals uh i i would
well accept possibly as an outermost
rapper
right i would never write that why
because uh i don't know that those
options are
actually valid options to f i just know
that they have the form of options
um well maybe we should try and clean
this up
um i mean does options pattern take
information about f as part of its
kind of sort of but not really
so options pattern takes up
uh takes information from alph from f
but only
when it's when you are retrieving
option values not in the pattern
matching
bits no somebody is is um noting on our
live stream that you attai
are very loud okay well i'll see if i
can
convince zoom to adjust the input level
would it make sense to have an arguments
pattern similar to
options pattern that took that's
interesting
yeah sort of the same sorts of arguments
as arguments options and
so in other words the way this would
then look is
args colon arguments pattern
opt's colon options pattern
well i mean i was actually thinking that
arguments pattern would sort of encaps
you know include the options pattern and
hook into
option value and
that sort of thing right but of course
but of course then the issue is
but then but of course then you don't
get any of the benefits
of you know test arguments because
well not only no i i'm saying either of
these idioms
no you you do if if
things so so the point is
if it if it's if it's literally just
args colon
argument options pattern
where no matter what the user right that
they said
so that's going to match a sequence but
args becomes bound to the separated list
that you would get from um arguments
options
list or whatever we or whatever we
called that
if you're following me yeah i'm
following you then
then you get then you get everything for
free
no you don't because
there are two things that you lose one
is
what was the original sequence and list
structure
of what was passed in and the other is
um i don't know how horrifying the
implementation
of this pattern matching us no
no you also lose something very
important is because you also lose all
the messaging
that you get from the current guys
because
oh because it doesn't matter because it
doesn't match so it doesn't match you
won't get a message every time it
doesn't match that would be crazy and
also you don't have the
string from the pattern matching
right pattern matching i mean this is
just like you might as well just place a
fortran style blob in here
you don't get all the stuff to do with
you know let's say your function was f
of you know x blank y blank blah blah
blah blah you don't get any of that
stuff
right so what problem are we trying to
solve let's let's
enumerate what problems are we trying to
solve
well we're trying to solve the problem
of how
of how to
well okay i'm i'm christopher
right we're trying to solve the problem
i mean this is the less compelling
of the two functions i'll grant you that
um
but these problems these
two functions collectively
um do two things they
um uh
they they issue the appropriate messages
for
invalid arguments and options of which
there are
probably 17 or 20 different ones
and this automates issuing the correct
message for you um
and they you know sort of
um arguments options list as opposed to
what what did we end up calling the
other one is it test arguments
check arguments check arguments um
you know this one rather than returning
true false you know
are these valid returns a list which
if you want to sort of you know
process all the options and arguments
and especially if you want to do them
held because it
supports you know you giving it
giving it a head other than list so it
can
return a held thing um
you know you sort of know upfront what
are what are your options and what are
your
options and you can you can
write based on that i mean that is a
much rarer use
even internally idiom
than uh
than the you know just testing
and issuing the correct messages
so this is this is you know step one i
mean we might
want a sort of you know define function
function
that sort of you know takes some time so
we shouldn't have this
discussion without christopher because
he's already worked on a bunch of i mean
this
whole enclosed confirm framework is not
precisely relevant to this
but it's closely related i mean that
clearly what we need to do here
is there is some idiom
that will be what the typical well
armored function definition will look
like
and we would like to get the advantage
of of both
our you know that's what we were trying
to do with
with forms like this it's get the
advantage of all the destructuring stuff
and you know you're concerned about how
we do the fall
through i mean for example you know for
example let's imagine that we had a
completely different construct
that was some kind of um
some kind of um
let's just imagine it was something like
this it's not a good name but something
like this
which essentially always matches okay
but which is responsible for generating
messages
in certain cases
do you get what i'm saying
um possibly
because that's what you're talking about
here
i mean this this function is not purely
for that
i mean people do write things like
right especially when there's potential
ambiguity between
options and arguments uh
that that they use this to to easily
separate the arguments and the options
and then they have
internally either a second function or a
switch
uh based on the length of the argument
which let's
try to avoid having to have a switch
i i i think we have here two fundamental
different paradigms people who would
start by checking everything and then
once
they checked everything is okay they go
and do the computation
and others which i think is more common
that we do the computation in
in general and only if no other than
value
applied then they will check the number
of arguments and emit errors
right that's why we have these two
functions one is useful in each
situation
exactly which functions are we talking
about argument
uh argument options and check arguments
so argument options is basically the
same as
check arguments only it returns true
false
and that's for you know you you write
all the down values
write all the patterns you actually care
about and then you have an
f x triple blank you know slash
semi-false
of of with the uh
i you know check arguments to issue
the correct message because you made it
to the fall through
bad down value
that's a very common idiom
and and the fact that we haven't exposed
to our users
the function that we all use to do that
we're talking about now well i check
arguments
yes i i think the other one is more
important than this one
right and we we went over we went we
went over all of this last time which is
why i'm a bit frustrated
okay look christopher should have been
here apparently he was added to the
wrong week's meeting
um i i think he'd be a very relevant
person to talk about this stuff and to
see how it relates to the confirming
closed
stuff let's let's let's not do this
again this time
what we agreed this time is arguments
options should be the name
and we will go back again and look at
this again okay but let's not do it
right now
and value queue that that is why chris
should have been uh
christopher should have been added so
because last time
the wrong week okay
terrific okay let's go on then to
storage location
okay draft draft page so how does this
relate to the external storage stuff
it has nothing to do with external
storage stuff well
should it have nothing to do with
external storage um
why can't i specify external storage an
external storage location
in you know external storage is
well okay fine it has something to do
with it in the sense of
i mean to the extent that you can store
these things in an external storage
thing um okay
so if i have what is it called external
storage object what is it called
i i don't know i am not sufficient
expert on these things
um new in 12.1 okay
so that was the the external storage
object is about to be
for uh amazon s3 and things like that
okay
right so to the extent it makes sense to
to the extent that it makes sense to
store any of these objects
in an external storage sure that could
be supported
but it has nothing to do with external
storage
as such right
okay so storage location is an option
okay is it also an option
for the neural net system and for you
know
other things that are what what else is
an option for
the moment it doesn't exist right it's
only in video generator but then it
could be propagated to appropriate
functions
right and in the discussion section
there's a list of
you know some obvious candidates that
that would want to take this
thing so let me ask you a question i'm
i'm going to show you something
okay i'm looking up something here this
is the gpt gpt2 transformer network
okay this might seem irrelevant but it
doesn't
why is this fuzzy just
i don't understand
oh my goodness sake what is going on
here why isn't this in the cdn
well maybe i'm not going to be able to
show you this this
seems to have something
no actually this isn't what i did
actually
never mind
but that should be in the cdn
okay unable to store data in notebook
what is that
what does that mean and why is it there
and and what
i mean this when did it get added as a
big red
thing uh probably
in 12 1 or maybe 12 1
1. i think it must be 12-1-1 because i
haven't seen it before
um and that
happens well it's possible that they
decided to just declare it as something
that can't but if they're using the
default behavior that means
the expression is sufficiently large
that
we don't want to embed it in the
notebook what is the what is the maximum
size constraint
uh yeah
it's it's somewhere in the couple of
hundred megabytes
uh range um i i
don't i think we turned it into a system
option
if people if people want to shoot
themselves in the foot
but given that people can you know also
crash their front ends by trying to
embed
objects which were too big that that's
basically why we put an upper limit on
what you can embed
i'm sorry what is the upper limit by the
way people are also still complaining
that you're too loud at all
um no wrong kernel
this seems to be 150 megabytes the
sequence product thing
okay so why is that not being stored
uh because what is this what is the name
of the upper limit
dude system options of typeset options
that's a very weird place for it to go
embed button byte count limit
so that looks like 128 megabytes to me
okay did we ever go over this because
this looks really goofy to me i mean
it's like the most important thing here
unable to store it's not that important
it's not important unless you try and
use it it shouldn't be a big red
earth condition well i
i i i mean it is an error condition if
you have things that you normally
um yes i know but it shouldn't be read
like that it shouldn't be
really jumping out on the page this
looks like an error it's not an
error it's simply that we can't store it
in the notebook and by the way it should
have more
text in there i mean in other words the
the you know
this this is not right this is okay well
fine
then all right you know take it to user
assistance this was signed off by john
you know i don't take every when
in the spring when when we did this
and you know we don't uh you know we
don't take every single bug fix
in the bayou so
um
okay i've i've adjusted my mic level so
hopefully much better well i'm sending
this to john since apparently
i i don't understand how this happened
it's wrong it needs to be fixed okay
i mean it just should not be bright red
like that
i i don't know that i agree with that i
mean it shouldn't be bright red like
that it is not an error
it is not an error it's what we've had
for the last however many years
it is a new thing that you can pick up
something like this and expect it to
work
no no no this is the complete opposite
of that because these things
right so you know do something a bit
a bit smaller right so i don't know how
you can make that
somewhat smaller but right if you do you
know a sparse array of
um
uh well that's too small because that's
you know
um
[Music]
uh but you know sparse array that might
have a different behavior if you quit
i'm not sure
that box will stir the information
inside it
why i'm not oh that's interesting well
that's
wrong if that's the case because then
why isn't why doesn't it have a big red
flag as well
uh presumably because
uh tali and company decided to implement
their own behavior instead of just
relying on automatic um or maybe it's
just something that's never
interpretable
right but this is telling you this thing
which is sometimes interpretable
is is composed of a live stream we
should have something which is a button
here which says
you know you can you can store as a
local object for example
or with one of these storage location
things right that's what this should
have
is the ability to have a storage
location where you can say you can store
it here or there
okay um right but if you do say sparse
array
here let me get uh
into a current kernel like
right so if you do sparse array of you
know compare sparse array of one two
three
look listen hey well let me let me
finish
okay and spicer and then sparse array of
range of 10 to the seventh
okay oh and so that that's
fine then then try okay and and now
and now do something like i don't know
ten to the six maybe
this this is a really this should never
happen steven will you please
just do that so i can show you that
there are three
states here a source right of what
try 10 to the 6.
right so this is telling you the thing
which you
normally when there's nothing there you
it's interpretable i understand
okay so this is just wrong wrong wrong
it's not wrong yes it's wrong it should
just say store now
and when you say store now you can't
store it in the notebook
where do you want to store it what
storage location would you like to pick
that's what it should do because this
statement data is not a notebook that's
the only statement you care about
unable to store a notebook for reasons
that we aren't even telling you
isn't the right thing this is the right
thing to have there
exactly this and say store now and why
is there a 16-point
what is that weird parenthesis there
look at that in that message
that should be fixed but that's a minor
bug okay
who's who's picking up these bugs is
devon picking up these bugs
devin are you taking notes or do i need
to take these notes
i'm here yes sorry i was did you get
that note or not
yeah i screenshot it okay
all right so listen the way this should
work is it should simply say data
and not a notebook store now and then it
should have some message here that
basically says you can't store this in
the notebook because it exceeds this
limit
so where would you what storage location
would you like to pick
okay and then it goes to the storage
location where it's telling you what the
possible places to store it are
so one one issue you can see for for
some functions like sparseride
is that they don't really support an out
of curve
mode right so sparse array of a file is
not a concept that
well it isn't yet it probably should be
okay not yet a concept but it should be
a concept am i making sense
i don't know that i agree with that the
whole point of sparse array is efficient
performance of
file back sparse array is just
no it doesn't exist yet because this
the whole point is it's not in the
notebook so it has to auto
import when you're using it
so i'm saying the only issue is this is
not being okay well
okay well but but that's a different
that's a different issue if you if you
want to solve that problem
you can go and solve that problem but
that's okay but that's what storage
location is doing for video no it's not
it is not solving that problem yes it is
video generator is auto importing
that's what it's doing or it's
effectively auto importing it's using it
it happens to work out of core so it
doesn't need to import it but
conceptually what it's doing is
it's using an external storage location
and effectively importing
even though it doesn't actually have to
import
i mean it's not the storage location
this is this store location just is this
the first argument
to export essentially we want to derive
parallel
yeah so exactly storage location is
telling you
where would you like to store this the
fact that there's a whole
out of core infrastructure is is sort of
gravy on the cake
but you know that that listen listen
listen look that
has nothing okay look we've got one
piece of functionality
which is this this thing here this video
generator thing
is supposed to so so show us an example
of where storage location will be used
for video generator
it it would just be a and yeah in this
case it's just uh
an example with audio generator but it
would be exactly the same thing
but what this is saying is what this
will look like
in the notebook is presumably something
like this no
it'll it'll look like first of all it
will look like an audio object and its
input form will be audio
of you know file of whatever just like
any uh
just like you could have typed in by
hand i understand it'll say something
like this so
i'm telling you the same thing this this
is this should be unified with this
there is no difference thing there is it
is completely different
one is dealing one is dealing with
arbitrary expressions
which are in memory and the other one is
dealing with you are specific
you are specifically generating a new
object which could be stored
in any of number locations okay which
including in memory
right i think we are discussing not
necessarily
wait wait wait wait not necessarily in
memory there are things which don't
support
in memory well it says in memory storage
location video
video for instance is not does not have
an in-memory version
but we had discussed this in the past
that it would be nice for audio
as well to be able to switch between
local
remote cloud or in memory modes
and and video is not going to have in
memory case
but if if we want to unify the ux for
that which we don't have
and this yes i i think that's fine
which we should do so let's go through
what we should do i mean the fact is
all of these things they're all large
objects
where in the case of video
it is never going to be stored in the
notebook right so that would be
another case here for storage location
is it's like a persistence location and
roman you should pipe up here it's like
a persistence location which can include
can persistence location include
in the notebook
no okay roman could you could romans say
something please
the system's location always maps to one
of
these that are listed here like local or
cloud
location or it could be in the kernel
can it be in the in the notebook
yes yes so why did why was the answer to
that question no
because the answer to the question is
because because
because this is not a persistent
location
location is it can be stored in the
notebook
right so well there's no sort of what's
the sort of about the sort of is
it's you know right it's going it's it's
going to be subject to
uh the same limitations as those summary
blobs
probably even worse well i i don't
understand what are you talking about
are you talking about the limitations
because we're we're setting an upper
limit to the size or what
uh well yes and because all right that's
not that's not relevant so
this is this here says we've got the
possibility of having a persistence
location which includes the notebook
right now some of these things
these types of of persistence locations
are different from your proposed storage
location
right yeah right because these are real
because storage location is for real
files that users might want
to find they're not for arbitrary
expressions
but the examples of storage locations
include
local objects and cloud objects so
i wonder whether we couldn't also just
allow a persistence of
persistent so the issue with that
i would say for example for video you
wouldn't you would not be able to
have a storage location in a front-end
session
because it really needs a file for local
object
it is a file backed local object for a
cloud object it would be a file back
cloud object so it is really as if i
said
something that requires a file to exist
somewhere and again it applies to
objects that are not files but
they are that are backed by files
well i no i no i don't think that's true
right i mean
speech synthesized well
right i mean it could conceivably work
for
for you know for uh you know url
download
or something right i mean oh yes yes so
right i mean i mean you are you because
you are working on audio and video
are concerned about the file backed
things but this could
apply equally to any fi thing that
generates files
okay yes so that's correct
okay so okay so so what's so what's more
relevant than persistence location
installer wool from
documents directory
these things have to be unified sorry
they have to be unified persistence
location also
what does what is its play with respect
to the documents directory
i don't think i'm asking roman how does
this
if i want to persist in the documents
directory how do i do it
i mean you could use a local object
in in any directory
no it says based on user home directory
so local to a computer yeah but local
local has
has the argument of a local object can
be an absolute
directory no i i understand that but i'm
not asking that question i'm saying
does this mean if i say persistence
location to local
does that mean it's using the documents
directory or something else
no it you no it uses the dollar
local base which you can change
well then how is that based on your home
directory
i mean i first of all i don't know what
based means
i mean that's not a very good
description i must admit
and on the other hand all of these have
subs you can say local
arrow dollar documentation directory
then it would use
that one as a base that is explained
further down on this page
local base appears to be
the default local base is something
determined here
what's that relative what is this dollar
what what is the other one
the documents one yatai that you've just
mentioned dollar wolfram documents
directory
i have no idea what the what the
relationship between these things is
or should be well then nor should there
be because one isn't an invisible
portion
of the file system and and is managed by
us
and which is the first one and the
second one
is just a place where we put things in a
standard location
for users to be able to find right so
both of them
everything in persistence location is
relevant
to data not in notebook store now
that's relevant any one of these places
we should be able to pull back the
sparse array
from a persistence location
well that yes but i mean
what will not work is the file file
backed things as
was explained earlier what i'm sorry
what won't work for what assistance
locations
are not guaranteed to be file based but
there's no problem storing a spouse away
in a persistent
persistent object anywhere fine
but so so then okay so the correct
behavior here is
data not a notebook store now where do
you want to store it
blump if it can't store in the notebook
you store it somewhere else
then what would be what would be put
here presumably and i don't know exactly
how this would work and we need to think
about that
is this is like iconized this is an
analog of iconize
but it is for out of core i can eyes if
you understand what i mean because if i
have an iconized object
right and i have something here if i say
i can eyes range of 100 or something
and i take that object yes right it
stores in a notebook but there's no
reason
why we can't have an analog of i can
eyes that stores not in a notebook
right in other words this as it resolves
could perfectly well do an import am i
am i wrong
well i it couldn't
i mean it could parse to an import it
couldn't we
it couldn't actually evaluate that
import until evaluation occurred
fine that's okay and
well i mean
it could in principle do that as part of
preemptive evaluation but it probably
shouldn't
i don't think there's any way to force
that
why why if it was a dynamic you could
force that but i don't think it's a good
idea
no the the
but well right dynamic evaluation and
main loop evaluation
are are two completely separate tracks
okay so it could parse to an import
right which is i think a correct thing
so i mean this would be
a you know i can eyes and store out of
core
so then all of these things can work the
exact same way
they can say if they're out of core they
you know
they become an import so then right
which means every time
you you evaluate this thing it's going
to be another import
well then why don't you use local cache
on the import
uh what what how does that help
because then it will cache it so it
doesn't have to re-import it
doesn't local cache caches
cloud objects in the local object that's
correct
which has nothing to do with the fact
that
if we if we create a little icon
that's an import right then every copy
of that icon is going to be another
import
well but all of i mean if you evaluate
any of these the
result will be stored in the kernel
right it's just a question of where it
comes from whether
right so we don't want to actually use
the word import we want to use some kind
of thing
that indicates that it is coming you
know like local cache right if we made
local cache of import work
then it will hash this thing inside and
if it ever sees that same thing again
it will come from the local cache
right i mean we want an analog of local
cache but for in memory
so it says yeah so so maybe if we did it
as like
once of import oh yeah that would work
that would work
that would work that would work that's
exactly right
right so then
okay so then that what this would do is
in your
so this is a reference
to a storage location
you know when it cannot handle out of
core
it has to pull it in with a once of
import
right when it can handle out of core
then it can merely be a reference
through something well well i i think
the objects with out of core will have
to have their own ui
that does this right i don't think the
right that the summary the general
summary box is going to start inspecting
and i agree right i agree but so
then the point is that that okay so this
case
we can then fix right so this case will
get fixed this will not show up here
this will just say store now and it'll
say how do you want to store it
and then this underneath here when the
data isn't in the notebook but it is
stored externally
um that should indicate that somehow
well i i think well i mean i guess i
don't know but i i would imagine that it
would
you know it would no longer look like a
summary box
because because it's not
it's not the actual expression
i i don't think i don't think something
by the time you get it to this point
uh no no it's not i mean
uh not if not if you do convert to
hold on you you cutted them as a
notebook you store the notebook
the thing wasn't saved in the notebook
what do you still have in the notebook
so what we have right now is basically
this summary blob
right so what it should probably say
is instead of data not a notebook store
now
it should say data not a notebook load
now because that's the state it's in
right
now it's in in the notebook right in the
notebook if you
save this thing out then
but but then what's the purpose of
because you have something in your
notebook that appears to be this
and where when you look at subsequent
lines in your notebooks that refer to
this
everything's happy until you try and
re-execute it when you try and
re-execute it you need to load it
and i mean it should probably auto load
itself if you
if you just shift down to evaluate it
but you should also be able to
load on demand well but
i see if it says data is not in notebook
load now i would
assume that this means that it loads it
into the notebook but it most definitely
will not
okay fine fine fine fine yeah i i don't
think i think i think that's the
wording needs to be changed slightly but
but basic idea is
it either loads it okay so um
well data data not in session
that sounds a bit wrong i mean it's like
like a you know
parliament is not in session or
something but you know what i'm saying
data not in
not right right but but but yes but okay
fine but
what what will that i mean that doesn't
do any good we've got to move on
look look look look it's pretty obvious
what what you need no no
it's completely wrong but can we talk
about can we maybe talk about the actual
storage location
the actual storage location isn't a good
idea as such because it needs to be
unified with these other things
right so no no it's
okay look no no no listen steven
right we you're always complaining about
why are things in random locations all
over my
file system we're trying we're trying to
you sort of
create a uniform interface to that right
which
apparently wasn't unified with the
persistence location for some reason
why would it be persistence location is
for expressions not for files
if i do speech synthesize if i do speech
synthesize to create some wav
file i want to know where that wav file
is i don't want it to be
in some mysterious part of the file
system this name is completely wrong
okay it's way too general for what this
is
what is this this is a file what is it
tell me what it actually is
well no it's a location where you will
restore
well it can be a couple of different
things but it's it's the
um it's the location
it is a a location to store the result
of
an operation possibly an out of core
operation
i don't think it's the result it's the
input isn't it here no
it's not the input it's the result
audio generator creates a file
and it doesn't output a file it out with
a file
that is backed by that file well it
outputs an audio expression and
that contains the file okay let's let's
let's go through the different things we
need to do
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to fix this okay
okay how about you look at what the
agenda that you know i actually spent an
hour preparing
okay because i found something here that
shouldn't have ever happened
okay so we this is something that needs
to get fixed all right we've made a note
of that it'll be sent to the relevant
folk
uh well
and and it's not real directly related
to
the item at hand all right so let's
bring this back in another meeting
please we'll bring this particular thing
back
okay
so the issue here is you want a place to
store
the output of this function that is
it's cache basically it's not really a
cache it's actually the output
well in some cases it might be a cache
and in some cases it might be
the actual output well which is it i
mean is it a cache that can be thrown
away
or does it then is it you know and in
the output blob what does it look like
well it i mean you get an audio object
or a video
object so it looks the same as audio or
video
particularly it isn't really there there
is a little icon if you go to the page
for audio
there is a small visual difference
between in-core
file-backed url-backed
open the notes the details
there the little waveform the file icon
there
link icon
okay
and and when i roll over this thing it i
see it says what the file name is there
yes
and and the tooltip is gonna show the
full name
okay so this is when i use audio
no no this is not an option when you use
audio
when you generate audio this can say
where you want this file the generated
file to be
but in the audio thing itself there is
no such option
correct but so the input form of an
audio
is what it's audio of file of blah blah
blah
or audio of url of blah blah blah
or audio of you know
okay so why is this
i don't understand here so so this is
because in audio you're saying it's a
directly if i say audio capture
you know it'll actually work here but
but hello there
okay right now where is that file
right and this is something that we were
thinking to right and
right this is something that was created
in wolfram documents directory
which maybe now there's some idea to
abandon dollar will from documents
directory
so you're proposing that this has a way
to say where to put it
exactly okay right right now there's a
method option or something
right all right fine so audio capture 2
storage location is an absurdly general
name for an
unbelievably specific thing what really
is this
yeah i think that problem comes i mean
first of all we use storage
in external storage for different things
the other thing is that
it is a kind of implementation centric
name which says
we store the output somewhere but for
the user it would be more like
result or file location or output
location
which is both of which are very weird
concepts
why is it an option by the way is there
a default for it or what
there are defaults for them yeah right
and which are i think are currently
well i think most of the audio and video
ones are now reasonably
there well the image ones haven't been
unified but
okay but i mean but is it the case that
you want to reset
the default storage location in a clean
way because otherwise
why isn't this just an argument to this
function
well for one thing it might be uh
it does become inside in one case either
undocumented we have it as the fourth or
fifth argument
carlo may remember which one yeah for
the example that you see
in in the usage box video frame map is
one where
storage location or whatever the name
would be would be useful at the moment
it's the
fourth argument okay it looks like it's
like something that could be
yeah the fifth argument yeah for
something that could have between two
and five arguments which
is a bit unwieldy okay all right okay
that's not gonna work
all right so
and also the advantage of it being a
storage location
of it being an option is that it can be
consistent across a bunch of functions
and you know you don't have to memorize
which position for
which function all right what is it
it's the location what is it
it's the location where the
generated res out of court at least as
envisioned here
and i think probably to other things
it's the location where the
generated out of core thing will be put
right so you speak
i think more general it's the location
where the data is stored
it could be in memory it could be the
directory where you create a file it
could be the file itself
right and so for right and let me point
out that so
for example one of the values we have
there is directory
yeah right and so if you don't like you
know
using documents you want to use you know
your foobar directory
but you don't want to have to manually
specify a name
but it automagically chooses between a
file and a directory specification
here correct what does it have to have a
trailing slash or what
so as the node says right there if the
directory already exists
then you don't have to put the trailing
slash if it's
if if you you know if you're not sure
whether the directory exists put in the
slash so it
isn't interpreted as a file name okay
all right okay which is just unnecessary
i mean that's not pretty but it's not
that's necessary
um
um
let's see
yeah is this really
even a location in the sense that we're
using it in other places
i mean it's somewhat similar to
persistence location right
it is somewhat similar um
[Music]
by the way can somebody report the fact
that the default option
default example here has a carrot which
is completely crazy
yeah i get it yeah that's clearly a
bad tagging in the in the main usage box
although i'm a bit surprised that
well there must just be some funny box
structure in there somebody made some
bad edit
and you know there's some invisible no
all sorts of people are commenting
on our live stream they don't want to
have to rewrite their code if they
switch between storing
cloud and local file system yeah that
that's the idea here is that you don't
have to do that
this is right then you could just do set
options
uh right so we can't because this if
this is the location
where it is looking for stuff
it's not where it's looking for things
it's where it's putting things
well how about something like
is that what it is or i mean it's not
default it's just
data destination if you want yeah yeah
i'm okay with data destination
or result destination well i guess it's
not necessarily the result as such so
maybe data is a better name
plus it's uh alliterative so it's like a
superhero do we is it
could it be something like a resource
related or is that confusing
no totally confusing
i'd love to have it be even more
qualified than this this is a it needs
to be an encrusted name
okay generated data destination
that's kind of long but it i think it is
that's a good idea
that's i think that will be okay
generated data destination
okay we we i can or i can do the renault
after okay hold on hold on hold on
um there
uh i do have one question if
well hold on okay so i mean
what does the automatic setting do
and by the way once you've used this
generated data destination the object
that comes back the audio that comes
back
then has a burnt in storage burnt in
location right
correct
yeah people on the live stream are
confused about the the
unifying backend file systems it's it's
not about that we already have that
pretty well under control
you can i mean they're just different
places where you can write things and
it's all pretty well unified
um this isn't about that this is simply
about a rather trivial question
of of when the thing is going to send
data to somewhere to tell it where you
want it sent
exactly but the question of of what we
have
that um i mean we actually have a pretty
well organized
set of of places you can send it to and
i don't see why oops
persistence did i misspell it yes i did
i should have picked that up um
you know presumably many of these
persistence locations should be allowed
as generated data destination presumably
well it's a little weird well i don't
think that like
colonel uh or
kernel session whatever it's called
right there's something where
which is effectively in it.m right i
don't think that's a good place to store
your data it's not however the local
notebook would be an okay
place to store it and that's not
something accessible from the syntax
it's correct because for some functions
we don't have an in-memory
modality no i understand it but i'm
saying a different thing
which is in notebook right if it's small
enough
well the question is can we we sort of
safely
actually store that right you know can
arbitr arbitrary binary data right i
mean isn't this the whole
multi-notebook problem of how do we
stick binary blobs into notebooks i mean
if it's small enough that it's
you can store it as an as a
you know as a normal expression then
sure
but if it's you know an mp3 that's
backing it up
you know i don't know that you can
necessarily just stick that into a
notebook
and sorry for cutting you off charlie i
didn't mean to do that oh well this is
no sorry this is notebook bundle idea
we've discussed it with john multiple
times
it i think it would be ideal eventually
if we could have
notebook bundles with jpeg assets and
mp4 assets and so forth yeah i i
agree the that that's an idea you know i
you know i have no objection to the idea
i just uh
you know i i feel like waiting for that
one is sort of like waiting for godot
so oh yeah of course of course but okay
syntactically the way that would work is
that that would be refer to a notebook
object is that right
although it's a little weird that it
will be referring to itself
i'm just worrying about the syntax
because you can't use a string that says
notebook there
you can't do strings that are like these
strings
because you're using that for file right
so one
so there are two possibilities either we
require the file wrapper both for files
and for directories
and then we can have magic strings
or we have so you know allow like
notebook as an option value why don't we
why don't we design defensively here and
put file as a wrapper for these
okay okay i i don't know you know what's
going to happen in the future but i
think this is a
this is a fairly obscure thing
that you know most of the time people
are going to use the default
but i think it's going to be very common
that people do set options
of a function with a directory
to get all of their files in one place
well then
in one known hey
that's what i was taking the destination
so they can set that
okay and have that be the default
and it could be automatic if you want as
the default
default so to speak
all right did we get that one uh yeah i
think so
i mean if you want to review it all
i mean i guess there's uh we haven't
sort of discussed it all well from
document directory in any detail if if
we if we want to sort of keep it or
maybe document it right now yes okay i
don't see a problem with it
okay i mean it's just
where you know it depends on the
operating system what the convention is
right
right it's basically uh
and i would sort of you know there are a
few things that are sort of stored in
random locations like chat
uses some bizarre product specific
location for its chats that should
probably move into wolfram documents
directory and just be consistent across
is there a sub directory in there under
war from documents directory is there a
subdirectory
that indicates chats and so on not chats
the only things that go there now are
images audio and video so those are the
three
subfolders right and i i would right now
chat uses doc something like
doc uh uh it uses documents directory
then a subdirectory that depends on the
particular front end you're using so
it's different
for mathematica or wolfram desktop or
finance platform and then chat which
just seems crazy i think
we should tell the chat people to just
move this into wolfram documents
directory
yeah but so long as who approves that
there should be a list of what the
subdirectories of wolfram documents
directory
are that do different things who who has
that list right now
well i guess it's the people in this
meeting okay so can we
make that list maybe devin can pull
together that list
so we can look at it right okay from
every group that thinks that they have
something that is going to be stored
there what is its subdirectory name
okay okay um and like we have to decide
is it chats or chat
and how does that work and so on okay
right right now it's
right so right now the list is video
audio and image i believe
right okay so then it will be chat would
be the except
those are partially collective nouns but
not really
so in other words what it would read is
document directory slash audio slash
whatever it's called foo whatever it is
yep right
so then it will be slash chat slash that
and so on
right
okay so just to be clear then i mean is
that consistent with the way that
persistence location
works okay what is this local
computer based on user home directory we
think that's misdocumented and needs to
be changed is that right roman
i mean it is explained further down what
the exact default is but
okay i would be curious because i i have
no idea what that is
default local base
it's a local object in dollar default
local base
which is this file here
right we looked at that before default
locations that's the standard dot wall
from
sub directory right that you can use for
many things
that's this which is in the library
subdirectory
yeah right as opposed to the documents
directory yes
was that something you are not supposed
to look at yourself
right yes
which again could be a valid location
which is what's happening with the local
object thing here
but the storage location here shouldn't
be saying
no this is wrong it shouldn't be saying
a particular local object it should just
be saying
i just want this thrown in the local
object store
well you might want a particular logo
you might but that's not the primary
thing you want what you want which is
what i suspected
is you want basically some subset of
these
like you want to say local which means
it's just going to be thrown in a local
object
cloud it's going to be thrown in a cloud
object and that
it is going to record in the output from
this function it is going to record
what you know which cloud object so i
think the correct thing
is that these strings correspond to the
persistence location strings and
obviously cookie managed
isn't a a a generated data destination
but um uh but local certainly isn't
cloud certain layers
i mean it is kind of the same thing with
directory versus file right
you specify the directory and then it
just puts it in an arbitrary
named file or you can specify the file
name yourself
same with local object you can say put
it in somewhere in a local object
or use this particular local object so
generated data directory
and sorry generated data destination
yes then becomes could be a string like
local that just means throw it in you
know the local object store
okay in a very rare case
it would be a specific local object
yeah that's what i was going to say it
would be nice to support both modalities
it's not a problem so long as we don't
have i mean
um okay all right so let's try and then
what's happening here
in that means that to get it in this
location in the library location you're
just saying
local generated document data
destination arrow local
i mean to be fair you could not do
it that easily as well if you said local
object with no arguments that would
create another
don't care okay right right but
but then if you wanted that as the
default you'd have to you use it as a
make it as a delayed value which is not
which is not a
you know which is not a problem for us
but it's probably not something we
want to offer arbitrarily so i think
we've got a design here all right let's
go
take a look at our last item on the
agenda for a moment yeah
didn't we discuss this last time i feel
like we did but
uh ian and uh and jose
should we did delete on this yes
we did discuss this is this not finished
i i i
think that the conclusion was so devin
put it there
so i i what devin should speak up what
is
was there something left we discussed
this so
the idea was that we will have this
option in echo timing and we need to
decide whether to put it somewhere else
like in compliance but by the way brian
on our live stream is talking about
notebook bundles which
we agree with this is what um various
people have been talking about is how to
make
how to get something which is a i mean
and that's something maybe we can talk
about
just a second here okay you want to send
somebody over the complete bundle of
stuff that they need to run this
notebook and its various attendant
pieces
what do you send them
do you see what i'm saying
what do you send them because you can't
send them
something the storage locations right
the only storage location that's going
to work for that is something relative
to the
file location of the notebook
see what i'm saying
if you send them a zip bundle the only
thing that they can do
where they will be able to unpack it and
have that bundle work
is for the sub elements you know the
data elements in the bundle
to be have relative values
have locations relative to the notebook
right can't have them go off in some
random directory somewhere
because there's no guarantee they even
have right permission on that that's
obviously not the right thing to do
so the only way that that definitely
works is if you threw it in the public
in a public
cloud location and the destination
the the user who receives the notebook
is simply themselves downloading
from the public cloud but that assumes
that you're prepared to expose
or get the permissions right for the
user you're sending it to it requires
that you know what user you're sending
it to it doesn't
it doesn't allow you to have something
where you just say here's the blob of
stuff
does that make sense
do you understand what i'm saying
so what should we do about this
uh maybe shoddy carlo
one thing that has in practice worked
for us very nicely is
owncloud dropbox like sharing
that you share a whole folder or a whole
folder i know that but i mean
but but but how you get the folder
transported is a secondary issue the
primary issue is that we don't currently
have
in the way the notebook is set up it
does not
live in a sort of flotilla of other
files
right the notebook is just on its own
but the point i'm making is the only way
this can work
is if the you know
what we could do is to have something
where
which i think is very weird but it's
sort of reminiscent of the way the web
works and where a bunch of other things
work
a directory which is really the notebook
directory
and if you in a sense conceptually sort
of
open that directory what you get
analogous to index.html is the notebook
opens but it
has its you know flotilla of support
files sitting around in that directory
do you understand what i'm saying i mean
we do that
manually by using relative paths right
if
but yeah yes yes yes yes it says inside
the notebook
that then has relative paths
see what i'm saying yeah but the point
is that what you've proposed doesn't
support that
yep right so that's not going to work
right because this i mean well it i mean
it's not going to work well why why
won't why
in this imaginary world where we have
notebook bundles
why couldn't we have a value no no
so here the right way to do this is
right i mean why can't you do
notebook directory bracket bracket as
your directory
right i mean then they'll be right next
to your current notebook
yes i understand although they'll be
sprayed as garbage into that directory
yeah and the references would still be
the absolute past name right
that's that's another thing that we will
have to look into it
and make sure all your video do not
resolve into absolute paths maybe we can
leave them as as relative pets
well but i mean we already support
relative past but they are relative
uh compared to uh you know
uh director the current directory not
compared to the notebook
so i'm not sure we can have two
different
well what no but but you need a way to
indicate
that a file which we which we have
partially but we don't have a
particularly clean version of it
that a way to refer to a file given a
name of a file
foo slash bar saying that that is
notebook
relative but that file name is notebook
relative
right i mean the front end has a way of
doing it right it's front end backtick
file name
and then you give it a list of elements
and so you can root it
at right and it doesn't even right the
whole point is that
unlike our file functions it doesn't
evaluate and so
it remains uh a list of things and so
you can root it at the current notebook
directory at the
dollar installation directory whatever
um i'm not sure well i mean
it sounds like what you're saying is we
need a version of that for system which
is fine
but it sort of coming i think that
i you know i think the hard parts will
be coming up with a good name and
documenting it clearly
versus the other file type functions we
have
right well i mean notebook relative
file right but why limit it to notebook
what else would you have you know
uh dollar installation directory dollar
base directory
user-based directory right all right so
maybe it's just relative file
so in other words that would be so then
what you'd say is relative
file i don't know whether i don't know
when it knows to default
to the notebook as opposed to so you
know be relative file
foo whatever it is dot you know wave or
something
comma and then it would be
uh well it's a little bit complicated
isn't it because it doesn't want to say
notebook
doesn't want to have the notebook object
because that's not persistent
it could just be a string notebook right
well if it used the persistence
locations
if it used that same family of
persistence locations yes
the crucial thing would be done to save
destiny
right except audio and video well i mean
well i i mean i i don't think these uh
this is particularly useful right i mean
i think you you want it
either to to perhaps be held
and and and uh you know then you can
you can use dollar variables to describe
the route or
or you'll need a way to sort of
represent
you know each this is but this is what
we need right because this is this is
the thing
that says if it is referenced
in a particular if the audio object
references a file it references a
relative
file that is relative to whatever
directory which may be completely
different
from the kernel's current working
directory whatever directory the
notebook is in
well yeah but you you're obsessed with
notebook and i'm saying i often need
things which are not relative to the
notebook
what else would it be relative to i told
you dollar home directory okay
installation directory
based directory those are not stored but
the point is that the things
that are in the notebook are what is
stored
that's the confusing thing that there is
this object that is stored
somewhere right it is part of the
notebook that is being stored
and that it has to call out and get
something
that is as if it was in the notebook
bundle
i'm saying that's what this is doing
well i
i just think that is too small to solve
but i don't think so i think that's a
critical problem to solve because that's
the exact problem
that everybody's referring to how do you
send a bundle of files that
can be rehydrated and work with the
notebook that you have that's the
problem being solved now
the other case you're talking about
which is i send something which is going
to be rehydrated in a home directory
right what is the thing that you're
dealing with in that home directory
that is relative to the current working
directory and it's not
relative to this thing that doesn't
really have a directory
that is this free floating notebook the
notebook implicitly defines a directory
by virtue of where by where of where
it's put whereas
in the case of the home directory thing
unless i'm missing something i don't
think that same
issue arises my home directory is
different on different computers
so if i want to set something up
relative to home directory i need to
you know a way that doesn't burn in the
value of
dollar home direction well it's tilde
whatever isn't it
okay fine but right but there may be
other things um
uh right but but tell th tell the
slashes is that
fine i don't disagree that the relative
file is a fine thing to have for that
case
but the important case we're dealing
with right now and the case that isn't
well specified
by anything at a valuation time is this
well
well yes it is it's not book directory
you can get it at valuation time
although it's calling the front end to
get that data well and what else could
it possibly do i understand but my point
is that it is
it's a different situation from the
situation in which you're you're purely
doing
kernel operations it's because there is
this file that is known to the front end
that is implicitly defining a location
i think the main point here is that
these relative files would be generated
as output
so that it doesn't so it doesn't uh
instantiate it there's no absolute past
name i think that's
that's the main difference it's already
oh look he contributed
his very self notebook relative path
yeah relevant
yeah and as i said the main issue here
is that the functions that
rely on this out of core assets need to
preserve
the held form of notebook relative path
because if not
it does nothing
project template
it's actually not necessary because if
you do if you
evaluate that resource function at the
beginning of your notebook and then you
can access everything with the resulting
absolute path
within the same session yeah but if you
then
save the notebook pass it to some other
person yeah it will still work
okay yeah but if you say audio of
notebook relative path for example that
will burn
the absolute path in the notebook and if
that's what you want to achieve okay
an output some an output cell that has
been burned then
that has the absolutely
yeah this is what i'm saying it needs to
be preserved in the
uh output form of whatever consumes it
right okay listen i think we should have
a separate discussion about
working towards notebook bundles and the
way that that should basically work and
it relates a little bit to the paclet
system which has already solved part of
this problem
right i mean it just puts things in a
directory and has a packet info file
that explains what all of them are
that make sense to people
yep okay so the junior version of that
is to just have a bunch of things in a
directory with things correctly
referenced
and presumably the paclet system could
also use this relative file mechanism
but the packet system has this whole you
know much more advanced mechanism
for just throwing things in a directory
and then having a separate
file that contains the meta information
about what goes where
or what the meaning of these different
things is
okay so let's bring back this issue
another time and
you know for what we're talking about
here i mean this is the
general direction that we should be
going in we've got much of it specified
but there's a little bit more to go
but for another time the um the concept
of um uh yeah this other this other
concept
okay anything else for right now
nope okay thank you particularly to
people on the
live stream for a lot of very useful
comments much appreciated
and thanks to the